you are so so fantastic and get out
really amazing yeah yeah I did a lot of
love first of all that's the elephant in
the room like you too I'm a big fan this
is kind of surreal moment for me to be
on the show which I like the like I was
in high school we used like starting out
do talk shows and he had a masturbating
band you know it's in another month it's
like 25 years since we started and I
forget most but we used to know one was
minding the store we were just doing the
weirdest stuff we could think of and not
knowing if anybody was watching and then
it turns out you were yeah that's all
sir so it wasn't internet so you didn't
know who else was watching it I thought
I was the only person watch it so this
is surreal being here it's an honor to
have you really excited about this this
is a you know I want to ask you you're
good friends you're good friends with
mr. Deon Cole yeah you guys sort of come
up together and Deon he he was in my
show when we when Andy and I toured the
United States about I don't know how
long ago was that was that eight years
ago nine years ago God what's happening
anyway we met Deon he's been blowing up
he's doing great
what made you decide like okay I want to
go I'm in comedy I'm doing stand-up but
I want to try acting was that something
that you thought okay I could do this no
I thought it was always the same
category so I didn't think it was ever
separation I thought if you act you had
to like know how to write and host and
and write and do stuff like cuz I looked
up to like Eddie Murphy and the Wayne
brothers and they did everything like
you see some I like Sammy Davis jr. you
learn about who knows how to sing do
comedy so I figured that you just
couldn't do one thing and I'm gonna say
this too what they would do we came
right out of your show yeah he always
talked about cuz he said where does
Gucci bill mm-hmm everywhere yes and he
he didn't had a Gucci money for real you
know they
he said everybody else had to like
regular stuff and like dirty gym shoes
and he's like a Gucci builder with his
chest hair showing it they were that
Gucci belt all the time you know we'd
like hang out by the pool idea him were
in a speedo and a Gucci belt
you